well let me ask about not just the crazy
but the cruelty so in um
you've written when reporting as Steve
Jobs was told you that the big question
to ask was did he have to be so mean so
rough and cruel so drama addicted uh
what is this answer for Steve Jobs did
he have to be so cruel for for jobs I
asked was at the end of my reporting
because that's what he asked said at the
beginning we're doing the launch of I
think
the iPad 2 it may have been Steve is
emaciated because you know he's been
sick and so I said it was what's the
answer to your question and he said well
if I had been running Apple
I would have been nicer to everybody
everybody got stock options and we've
been like a family and then I I don't
know if you know was we like a teddy
bear he paused he smiled and he said but
if I'd been running Apple
I don't think we would have done the
Macintosh or the iPhone so yeah you have
to
sometimes be rough and job said the same
thing that musk said to me which is he
said people like you love wearing velvet
gloves no I don't know that I've worn
velvet cloth often but you like people
to like you you like to sweet talk
things your sugarcoat things he says I'm
just a working class kid
and I don't have that luxury if
something sucks I got to tell people it
sucks or I got a team of B players well
musk is that way as well and it gets
back to what I said earlier which is
yeah
I probably would wear velvet gloves if I
could find them at my haberdasher uh and
I do try to sugarcoat things but when I
was running CNN it needed to be reshaped
it needed to be broken it needed to have
certain things blown up and I didn't do
it you know so
bad on me but it made me realize okay
I'll just write about the people who can
do it well that thing of saying I think
probably both of them but Elon certainly
saying things like that is the stupidest
thing I've ever heard
by the way I've heard Jeff Bezos say
that I've heard Bill Gates say that I've
heard Steve Jobs say it I've heard Steve
Jobs saying about a smoothie they were
making it a whole food or something I
mean people they use the word stupid
really often and you know who else used
it Arrow musk he kept spanking Elon
stand in front of him and saying that's
as stupid as saying you're the stupidest
person you'll never amount to anything
um
I don't know you know as John McNeil the
president of Tesla said
do you have to be that way probably not
there are a lot of successful people who
are much kinder
but um
it's
sometimes necessary
to be much more brutal and honest
brutally honest I would say then people
like
or when Boss Of The Year trophies
well as you said this kind of idea did
also send a signal this idea Steve Jobs
of a players it did send a signal to
everybody
it was a kind of encouragement to the
people that are all in